servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich stehe auf einer
wiese in unserem garten und heute
erzähle ich euch 7 fakten über mich die
die welt bewegen
und ja gar die bewegen die welt genau
bei der erstellung der fakten max
geholfen der auch jetzt gerade hinter
der camp steht gut anfang damit fakt
nummer eins ich war früher ziemlich fett
herbert reiter ich bin neuer l winken
ich war früher ziemlich fett leute und
zwar glaube ich habe ich mir zu 16 oder
so und habe ich keinen sport gemacht zu
der zeit habe ich damit 100 kilo gewogen
mit 16 jahren ich war so 185 groß damals
vielleicht ein kleiner zwischen 80 und
100 kilo gewogen heute ist es alles
wissen besser heute die ich glaube ich
auf 1 meter 90 so 84 kilo also hat sich
das zumindest wieder gelegt man das als
fakt 2 der besteht immer noch
ich bin nämlich nach wie vor eine person
die das beschießen zeitmanagement aller
zeiten hat was ist zeitmanagement
einfach dass ich selten gebacken kriegen
mir die zeit so einzuteilen wie ich dir
eigentlich brauche ich komme fast immer
zu spät
ich muss gestehen dass morgen manchmal
schon passiert ist dass ich dinge zu
spät abgegeben habe und über richtig
probleme bekommen hat und ja ich bin
generell eigentlich ziemlich gut aber
vor allem wenn es um zeit geht es
passiert so auf dass sie zu ihrem freund
sagen so kommen wir treffen uns um 15.30
und das ist okay alles klar
und dann denke ich mir so um 15 uhr 20
braucht 15 minuten für den weg da kann
ich nur fünf minuten chillen und dann
bin ich aber endet um 15 uhr 81
milliarden da 30 fakt nummer drei
ich fahre gerne nachts auto also mit
nachts meine ich nicht dass ich so von
10 uhr ist 12 uhr autofahrer
ich war die ganze nacht durch und
teilweise zurück
die störten uhrzeiten ich kann mich
erinnern ich bin einmal um zwei uhr
nachts von seinem studienort bloß
gefahren und bin dann sechs uhr morgens
bei meiner familie angekommen ich weiß
nicht mag es einfach so ein bisschen die
ruhe die stille die man beim autofahren
packt nummer vier
ich habe extrem früh mein abitur gemacht
das war damals mit 16 jahren mit 16
jahren sein abitur gemacht was daran lag
dass ich früher eingeschult wurde damals
mit fünf und dann eine klasse
übersprungen habe nämlich die führte das
alles zusammen hat dazu geführt dass ich
mit 16 jahren sein abitur gemacht hat
was der junge ist aber gar nicht mehr so
gut weil man überhaupt keine ahnung was
mit seinem leben machen sollte man ist
man denkt ja okay ich will ins ausland
gehen vielleicht welche organisation
nimmt mich alles
am ende kann man gar nichts machen man
fact ich mag's hat man aber jetzt gerade
gemacht und so passt uns nur eineinhalb
jahre älter als vier jahre früher gehabt
weil ich einmal wiederholt habe wasser
später holte war habe ich wieder geholt
der war weggeflogen ich habe wiederholt
wird einlage dauert leider konnte ich
schaue mich besucht 103 nicht schlimm
tag der lehre
du kannst schon jörling ich will gehen
jörling macht trotz fakt 5 ich verbringe
ungefähr meinen ganzen tag im internet
was ist für dich über vielleicht nicht
überraschend ist oder doch überraschend
welche nebenbei noch studieren also
ungefähr den ganzen ganzen tag entweder
auf youtube oder auf youtube wasserseite
ist so ungefähr so wie mein geld noch
nicht ganz so peinlich nicht kennst ja
auf jeden fall verbringe ich meinen
ganzen tag auf diesen seiten und
eigentlich sollte ich etwas sinnvolles
mit meiner zeit anstellen
sex ist meine augen sehr wichtiger fakt
aber nicht so fröhlicher und zwar habe
ich schon meine video erzählt das habe
ich hier oben verlinkt dass ich früher
in meiner schulzeit sondern möchte von
mobbing wurde und das ist fakt nummer
sechs ist jetzt nicht so der fröhlichste
fakt aber ich glaube es ist eine
richtige sache weil es leute halt
beeinflusst so aber ich darf jemand der
so was erlebt hat in der schulzeit
verhält sich anders als jemand der so
etwas nicht erlebt hat und wenn wir mehr
wissen wollte und mich damit umgegangen
bin wie gesagt da direkt neben dem ohr
ist aber schweigt sie manchmal kann sein
trommelfell platzen wenn man daran trägt
die letzte fakt nummer sieben ist ein
bisschen näher rankommen
denn ich hab immer im auge ich weiß
nicht warum
und ich habe ja keine ahnung wieso
dieser schwarze fleck dabei im auge ist
wir spekulieren das ist mal was zu tun
hatte dass er weiß wie kinder waren mit
feuerwerk gespielt hat man ich hatte so
eine reibe feuerwerk was also keine
zündschnur die mal gemacht sondern so
eine reibe kopf und den er mit seiner
art pfeile an
danke das feuerwerk los ich war
natürlich so smart dass die etwas auge
zuhalten den kameras ins auge und ich
habe geschrien habe ich damals gesagt er
macht schon mal nach meinem auge
irgendwas ist hat er geschaut vergleich
der dass das schwarze fleck damals war
sie acht war oder sieben so also maximal
früher 8 und ich wir sind daran macht ja
okay und dann hat er sich angeschaut was
mein auge ist und meinte du hast ein
schweizer fliegt er war
du kannst wirklich daherkommt aber so
wie es uns immer erklärt und auf jeden
fall habe ich ihn schatten der mauer
wird dann noch mal gucken
genau die leute denn es können nur leute
das war's vom heutigen video das waren 7
fakten über mich die er wahrscheinlich
noch nicht wusste